chapter four get and stay in sync
remember that for an organization to be
effective the people who make it up must
be aligned on many levels from what
their shared mission is to how they will
treat each other to a more practical
picture of who will do what when to
achieve their goals yet alignment can
never be taken for granted because
people are wired so differently we all
see ourselves in the world in our own
unique ways so deciding what's true and
what to do about it
takes constant work alignment is
especially important in an idea
meritocracy so at Bridgewater we try to
attain alignment consciously continually
and systematically we call this process
of finding alignment getting in sync and
there are two primary ways it can go
wrong cases resulting from simple
misunderstandings and those stemming
from fundamental disagreements getting
in sync is the process of open-mindedly
and assertively reflecting on both types
many people mistakenly believe that
papering over differences is the easiest
way to keep the peace they couldn't be
more wrong by avoiding conflicts one
avoids resolving differences people who
suppress minor conflicts tend to have
much bigger conflicts later on which can
lead to separation while people who
address their many conflicts head-on
tend to have the best and longest
lasting relationships thoughtful
disagreement the process of having a
quality back-and-forth and an
open-minded and assertive way so as to
see things through each other's eyes is
powerful because it helps both parties
see things they have been blind to but
it's not easy while it is
straightforward to have a meritocracy in
activities in which there is a clarity
of relative abilities because the
results speak for themselves such as in
sports where the fastest runner wins the
race it is much harder in a creative
environment where different points of
view about what's best have to be
resolved if they're not the process of
sorting through disagreements and
knowing who has the authority to decide
quickly becomes chaotic sometimes people
get angry or stuck a conversation can
easily
wind up with two or more people spinning
unproductively and unable to reach
agreement on what to do for these
reasons specific processes and
procedures must be followed every party
to the discussion must understand who
has what rights and which procedures
should be followed to move toward
resolution we've also developed tools
for helping do this which you will hear
later in the appendix and everyone must
understand the most fundamental
principle for getting in sync which is
that people must be open-minded and
assertive at the same time thoughtful
disagreement is not a battle its goal is
not to convince the other party that he
or she is wrong and that you are right
but to find out what is true and what to
do about it it must also be
non-hierarchical because in an idea
meritocracy communication doesn't just
flow unquestioned from the top-down
criticisms must also come from the
bottom up
for example this email was sent to me by
someone who worked for me after a
meeting with clients all the senior
people at Bridgewater including me are
routinely criticized and judged by our
subordinates from gym h2r a Lionel Kaye
Greg J Randle s David a subject feedback
on ABC meeting ray you deserve a d-minus
for your performance today in the ABC
meeting and everyone that was in the
room that saw you agrees on that harsh
assessment give or take half a grade
this was especially disappointing for
two reasons one you have been great in
previous meetings where the subject
mattered to be covered was the same and
two we held a specific planning meeting
yesterday to ask you to focus tightly on
culture and portfolio structuring
because we had only two hours to have
you cover those two topics we cover the
investment process have Greg do the
observatory and have Randall do
implementation instead you took a total
of 62 minutes I measured but worse you
rambled for 50 minutes on what I think
was portfolio structuring topics and
only then got to culture and you talked
about that for 12 minutes it was obvious
to all
of us that you did not prepare at all
because there is no way you could have
been that disorganized at the outset if
you had prepared